hey it's becca
rebecca shanley nathan daniel ransom
tommy
with the outdoor boys youtube channel
and today we are going to whittier
alaska to do some fishing and kayaking
and other fun things are you excited
yeah
me too this will be
[Music]
fun so luke and jacob they are in
ketchikan alaska today they're taking
the ferry up from washington and we're
going to meet him in a few days so we're
out having some fun
before they come we're driving along the
cook inlet then turning an arm and it's
beautiful hoping to see some beluga
whales
we stopped by windy point to see if we
can see a pretty view and see some
bluego whales
that's really pretty
no whales yet
it's a booger whale it's a booger whale
we stopped by willowa to see some salmon
see that one it's pretty cool
what'd you think tom
let's get back in the car we're on the
way to portage and then on the way to
whittier gonna do some fishing see we
can see do some kayaking it'll be fun
and everybody already left me i gotta
and go
back when i was a kid we could see the
porridge the glacier here
and my dad was a kid
the glacier was back down the road
pretty
high are you
are can i go back crazy the call yeah
so we're here waiting to go through the
whittier tunnel whittier tunnel was
built back in like
1915 or so as a railroad tunnel and then
back around 2000 they turned it into a
highway tunnel and a railroad tunnel but
it's only one lane it's about two and a
half miles push everyone through one
direction
and they wait
put everyone through the other direction
and they wait and have the train go by
didn't you work on this dan i did
actually i worked on it and lived in
whittier for about two weeks uh during
the into the construction of it when we
were first married when he was first
married to miss rebecca me
we are both rebecca nichols yeah but you
are the first
mosquito i love the waterfalls on the
mountains there but you're so pretty
tunnel fires can be really dangerous
because there's nowhere for the heat to
go they have eight different safe houses
built into the solid rock
fire and they have their own air supply
and power
so we're just chilling waiting to go
through the winter tunnel
the sun actually came out this is good
here we go
there's the one apartment building where
pretty much everybody lives in the city
hoping for fish right
or kayaking that's good that's good get
dressed in gear since it's kind of cold
and wet i over pack so i'm pulling out
the wool socks and the rain gear this
will be good
well we're here in whittier we're gonna
do a little fishing a little kayaking
see how it goes
weather's lovely
salmon are definitely in
oh you already got your socks wet
dang that was fast
this is interesting to watch from above
the water's so clear that i can see when
it hits the fish and like snags them in
the back or something that's awesome
fish on
this is really cool
what do i do grandson tell me did you
catch it with your own hand yeah
i jumped in the water and wrestled it
i wrestled this thing out okay let me
take your picture that's pretty awesome
hold on i was confused i saw some
and suddenly i what
there's fish everywhere and i didn't
catch one
oh he's putting up a fight
okay actually i learned this trick was
fly fishing
and here's her pink oh that's a monster
look at that guy
oh ransom's got a fish
you guys gonna go out on the kayak
you guys going out kayaking on this
lovely day oh yeah perfect day for
kayaking
[Music]
well stanley and i are enjoying the fine
winter weather
sure
it is really pretty though
it's a bit wet
because this is technically the ocean
well you go with me i don't really want
okay
sound
you can do it becca
bye becca
we're gonna try a little fly fishing
i've never done fly fishing in the ocean
or for salmon actually i've only done
fly fishing once like last week but i
liked it so
we're going to try it
so this is a wet fly it will be there
there's no quiet one
we'll be using wet flies okay so it's an
articulated flight yeah
i just want to think about
it the hook bounces around
but dana's a fish
that was fast
you tend to get more mouth fish with the
fly rod
okay so
okay becca's got one right here keep
your tip up keep your tip up
giving her a fight look at that
her first salmon on a fly rod all by
herself
you're playing them good job look at
that
[Music]
yeah nice job becca
whoa and there you go perfect
perfect
didn't even have to get the flyers out
good job
okay becca once again got another fish
[Applause]
it's about her third i think
keep pulling in keep rolling in
oh no
yay i caught a fish
but i broke your rod i'm really sorry
that's okay
that's more exciting look at that guy
look at all those teeth on him
oh i think we're done
oh no
oh my god little guy bro oh no
my second time fly fishing
and i broke the rod
i'm sorry dan
what happens well it was fun while it
lasted
well that was super fun while it lasted
oops thank you dan
i'm sorry oh don't feel bad about it
it was really fun though it died in the
line of duty died in the line of duty i
appreciate it
it was really fun
tell luke that i want to go fly fishing
yeah see now you just you know you have
to make your own rod and reel go out
i even smell a little bit like luke
i miss him
i hope he's having fun on the ferry with
jake
so long with your face
but very wet
luke's been hit by lightning did you
know that yeah
we're back in the tunnel headed to
anchorage
the snickerdoodles look awesome
the cinnamon rolls look awesome oh my
goodness
should we get a donut
um or that a giant cookie or a giant
cinnamon roll or a giant they're just
really big any of those yummies should
we get everything oh no no no no
maybe maybe five or six different things
okay
oh my goodness huge stack it's kind of
like the big stack of pancakes but
they're each one is a different kind of
cookie and it looks really good and
don't forget you guys have been wrong as
big as your face because your face oh
that looks really good
so what's the chances that they won't
ruin their dinner
don't eat all of it okay because i don't
want to ruin your dinner got it
i have a snickerdoodle the size of my
face
well guys did you have a good time
yeah yay
well thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos by the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to
click subscribe
nailed it there are new videos every
saturday morning and a shout out for all
the outdoor girls who love watching
these videos we love them too
yeah
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching